au mois d'octobre la vie culturelle
reprend peu à peu il en est ainsi à bois
d'arcy après son ouverture de saison la
grange de la tramblais accueil
yvan le bolloc'h et ma guitare s'appelle
reviens pour un spectacle entre musique
et
en
et internet
l'antenne relais
dans cette salle qui peut accueillir
jusqu'à 370 personnes la programmation
se veut éclectique théâtre chants et
danses et les fauves aux responsables de
la programmation nous confie ses coups
de coeur ça va être père koçak une
compagnie irlandaise qui est en trop se
tromper les pailles et tambours du bronx
qu'un spectacle assez hallucinant de
percussions à la fois il est tombé au
japonais et des petits yeux pleins de
sable donc c'est un vrai spectacle
drôles étonnants anciens possible que
j'aie une particulière attention au
château moderne ça contemporain
compagnie belge qui s'appelle le aoki
juin ce texte est le mètre carré qui
paraît être un spectacle assez c'est un
rat comptable c'est inexplicable c'est
une expérience à vivre autour de la
grange la médiathèque de la tramblais de
structures complémentaires et une salle
qui s'appelle le grenier au premier
étage une très jolie salle sous les
poutres qui est principalement dédié à
toutes les animations jeunesse de la
médiathèque c'est à dire l'heure du
conte
une fois par mois un club signer une
fois par mois également une animation
pour les tout petits qui s'appelle
croquelivres qui est fait en partenariat
avec les services de la petite enfance
la boîte à meaux en fait
l'idée c'est de proposer des lectures
spectacles qui donne envie
éventuellement d'aller relire ou d'aller
découvrir des auteurs voilà qu'on n'a
pas forcément l'habitude d'entendre
et puis toujours dans un esprit de
convivialité voilà à la fin de chaque
boîte a beau on discute on échange
autour d'un verre parmi les têtes
d'affiché retrouvée sur la scène de la
grange la tremblay guy bedos ou charles
berling
la programmation complète est disponible
sur internet